i've
also read at this point i think every
biography of putin english
uh english biography putin i need to
read some russians
obviously i'm mentally preparing for a
possible conversation with putin
what is your first question to putin
when you have them on your
on on on the podcast i
i it's interesting you bring that up
first of all i wouldn't tell you
but you can't give it away now uh but i
actually haven't even
thought about that so my current
approach and i do this with interviews
often that's but obviously that's a
special one but
i try not to think about questions until
last minute
i'm trying to sort of get into the
mindset
what and so that's why i'm soaking in a
lot of stuff not thinking about
questions
just learning about the man but
in terms of like human to human it's
like
i would say it's i don't know if you're
a fan of mob movies
but like the mafia which i am like good
fellas and so on
he's much closer to like mob morality
which is like well maybe i could see
that
but i like your approach anyways of this
um the
extreme empathy right it's uh a little
bit like
you know hannibal right like if you ever
watch the show hannibal right they had
that guy
um um well you know hannibal of course
like uh
yeah but there were those tv shows well
and focused on this guy will durant uh
who's a character like
extreme empath right so in the way he
like catches all these killers is he
pretty much
uh he can empathize with them right like
you can understand
why they're doing things they're doing
right yes it's a pretty uh excruciating
thing right like because you're pretty
much like spending half your time in the
head of
evil people right like but i mean i
definitely try to do that with uh
with other so you you should do that in
moderation but yeah
uh i i think it's it's a pretty safe
place
safe place to be like one of the cool
things with this podcast and
i don't know you didn't sign up to hear
me listen to this but
uh that was interesting i uh
and uh what's his name chris lautner
who's a google
uh oh he's not google anymore sci-fi
he's legit he's one of the most legit
engineers i talk with
i talk with him again on this podcast
and one of the he gives me private
advice a lot
and he said for this podcast i should
like interview
like i should widen the range of people
because that gives you much more freedom
to do stuff like
so his idea which i think i agree with
with chris is that
you go to the extremes you just like
cover every extreme base
and then it gives you freedom to then go
to the more nuanced conversations
it's kind of i think there's a safe
place for that there's certainly a
hunger for that nuanced conversation i
think
amongst people where like on social
media you get canceled for anything
slightly tense that there's a hunger to
go full
right you go so far to the opposite side
it does and it's like demystifies it a
little bit
right yeah there is a person behind
all of these things yeah and that's the
cool thing about podcasting
like three four hour conversations that
that it's very different than the
clickbait journalism it's like the
opposite that there's a hunger for that
there's a willingness for that yeah
especially now i mean how many people do
you even see face to face anymore
right like this you know it's like not
that many people like in my day today
aside from my own family that like i
said across
it it's sad but it's also beautiful like
i've gotten the chance to
like like our conversation now
there's somebody i guarantee you there's
somebody in russia
listening to this now like jogging
there's somebody who is
just smoke some weed sit back on a couch
and just like enjoying
like i guarantee you they will write in
the comments right now that yes i'm in
st petersburg i'm in moscow whatever and
and
we're in their head and they have a
friendship with us
and i'm the same way i'm a huge fan of
podcasting
it's a beautiful thing i mean it's a
it's a weird one-way human connection
like yeah
before i went on joe rogan uh and still
i'm
just a huge fan of his so it was like
sorry we had
i've been friends with joe rogan for 10
years but one way
yeah from this way the from the saint
petersburg way yeah the san francisco
it's a real friendship i mean now it's
like two-way but it's still
surreal it's yeah and that's the magic
of podcasting i'm not sure what to make
of it
that voice it's not even the video part
it's the audio that's magical that i
don't know what to do with it
but it's people listen to three four
hours yeah
we evolved over you know millions of
years right to be very fine-tuned
things like that right yeah no
expressions as well of course right but
uh
you know back back in the day on the you
know on the savannah you have to be very
attuned to you know whether
you had a good relationship with the
with the rest of your tribe or very bad
relationship
right because you know if you had a very
bad relationship you're probably
going to be left behind and eaten by the
lions yeah but it's weird that the tribe
is different now like you could have a
connect one-way connection with joe
rogan
as opposed to the tribe of your physical
uh
vicinity but that's all that's why like
you know it works with the podcasting
right but
it's the opposite of what happens on
twitter right because all those nuances
are removed right you're
not connecting with the person yeah
because you don't hear the voice
you're connecting with like an
abstraction right it's like some
some stream of tweets right and it's
very easy
to assign to them any kind of like evil
intent
you know or dehumanize them which you
it's much harder to do when it's a real
voice right because
like you realize it's a real person
behind the voice
you